hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory have
you ever wondered how spells are created
well the answer is simpler than you
might have guessed
it's all thanks to a handful of
extremely cunning witches and wizards
who saw a problem in their life and
tried to create a magical solution as we
look through the historical records of
The Wizarding World we find no shortage
of famous Wizards and witches who have
left their mark on Magic and created
spells that are still in use in modern
times today we're going to take a look
at some of the most famous spells and
their creators as we go over the history
of magical inventors let's get into it
but dear Ali and Ben copper Ben copper
and his friend Padilla Ali were both
students at Hogwarts School of
Witchcraft and Wizardry in the mid-1980s
although copper was sorted into
Gryffindor and Ali into house Ravenclaw
the two ended up creating a spell
together this particular magical attack
was an updated version of the
traditional knockback Jinx the students
at Hogwarts had used for Generations
named flippendo maximum due to its
greater effects this particular spell
might have actually been quite dangerous
for the students since it caused them to
fall backwards and oftentimes their
heads would bounce violently off the
stone floors of the school at a
different time during her stay at
Hogwarts bedia Ali created another spell
this one summoned a dazzling meteor
shower in the sky and as Ali would later
come to discover she could even use the
incantation to transform the paintings
at Hogwarts and filled them with their
own falling stars William Weasley
William Weasley was the oldest member of
the Weasley siblings his job as a curse
breaker often took him far away from the
Weasley's family home known as the
borough during his time away Bill used
his magical abilities to become one of
gringott's greatest employees in a
showdown in Egypt Bill even defeated a
mummy but perhaps the greatest
achievement came during the second
Wizarding War during that time Bill
invented a spell that would block any
dark mark wearing Death Eater from
entering a building this barrier would
become pivotal in the battles that the
Order of the Phoenix would participate
in throughout the war Severus Snape as a
former Death Eater and a member of the
Order of the Phoenix Severus Snape LED
an interesting life and in addition to
his many missions in service to Albus
Dumbledore Snape was actually quite an
accomplished spell maker during his time
as a student in Hogwarts and as a
Professor Snape created many of these
spells that students use to this day
Snape's langlook curse was a particular
popular one with a simple swing of a
wand this spell would lock a target's
tongue to the roof of their mouth
preventing them from speaking as a
frequent victim of bullying Snape
undoubtedly found this spell useful when
he was on the receiving end of jeers in
the same vein Snape also created a spell
that would cause anyone nearby to
temporarily experience a deafening
so that he could gossip without fear of
being overheard this Bell was called the
mafliato charm and Harry Potter often
used it in class but perhaps Snape's
most famous curse was sectum sempra this
one caused painful cuts to magically
appear on its victim's skin Harry used
it invites against Draco Malfoy the
inferi who protected one of Voldemort's
horcruxes and even against its creator
Severus Snape himself gilderoy Lockhart
Professor gilderoy Lockhart's Legacy
isn't one to be very proud of on his
journey to eventually becoming a star
teacher at Hogwarts Lockhart had
regularly exaggerated his own abilities
and even lied about his achievements he
was famously exposed as a fraud when
confronted by Harry Potter and Ron
Weasley shortly before the pair entered
the Chamber of Secrets unfortunately in
the aftermath Lockhart erased his own
memory but before his downfall gilderoy
Lockhart actually created one of the
most charm
narcissistic spells in The Wizarding
World through an incantation Lockhart
was able to project His Image into the
sky via the holographic spell so that
everyone around could enjoy his Beauty
Albus Dumbledore we can't be sure how
many spells Albus Dumbledore created but
according to the record of Hogwarts
there's only one that was attributed to
him this was the Patronus charm a
Communications Bell during the second
Wizarding War Dumbledore smartly
realized there were too many ways that
the Order of the Phoenix could be
deceived and to be lured into traps by
false messages to combat this he created
a spell that would use an individual's
Patronus to transmit messages since this
was always unique to a non-dark wizard
Tom Riddle Tom Riddle more famously
known as Lord Voldemort was an extremely
accomplished spellcrafter before his
resurrection riddle created more Mort
the spell that set the sky light with
the dark mark and he even designed the
spell that would kill Albus Dumbledore
the curse that rested on the Ring of
marvelo gaunt yes Dumbledore died to
Avada Kedavra but this spell would have
killed him Tom Riddle also created a
spell that allowed him to fly without
the use of a mount or Brum this was
called unsupported flight and although
the films depict many Death Eaters
achieving a similar feat it was actually
quite rare it was a technique that
Wizards and witches had spent centuries
trying to master and it wasn't until Tom
Riddle's discovery that it was finally
perfected basil Horton and Randolph
Keach basil Horton and Randolph Keach
were a pair of famous quidditch players
but they were more than just a pair of
Falmouth members of the Falmouth Falcons
they were also the creators of the Comet
Trading Company you might recognize this
name because it's responsible for some
of the most famous broomstick models in
production well Horton catches Comet
broomsticks were so beloved by quidditch
players for their incredible speed and
also their sudden stopping Precision
this was actually achieved by a spell
that the pair of Founders created known
as the breaking charm it allowed their
broomsticks to stop on a dime and was
also quite safe Miranda goshawk over 50
years before Harry Potter's final
showdown against Lord Voldemort a young
witch named Miranda goshawk created a
pretty gross spell Miranda's goal was
simple she wanted her older siblings to
finally listen to her and stop walking
all over her to do this Miranda created
the bat bogey hex which transformed her
Target's boogers into disgusting
bat-like creatures thanks to its
revolting nature the hex was massively
popular among students at Hogwarts at
one point a student from an unknown
house actually used the hex to cause
bats to fly out of every member of his
classes nose Lavina monk Stanley Lavina
monk Stanley was a witch who lived
hundreds of years before the rise of
Lord Voldemort during her life as an
unspeakable in the department of
mysteries in the 18th century Lavina
spent her time surrounded by the unknown
her job dealt with the mysteries of
death time love and Consciousness but
that wasn't quite enough for her monk
Stanley also decided to create her own
spells she was the witch responsible for
the Wonder lighting charm which caused a
wizard one tip to cast a bluish light
she also created the opposite spell the
wand extinguishing charm which
essentially turned the light off
Elliott Smithwick a decade or two before
basil Horton and Randolph Keach created
the comic broomstick company a wizard
named Elliot smethwick made an important
contribution to broomstick riding
realizing that the devices were quite
uncomfortable to ride Elliott created
the cushioning charm which would create
a magical seat wherever a rider sat
Daisy penafold like many other quidditch
players and fans Daisy penafold was a
witch who used her expert skills as a
spellcaster to create a charm for the
sport her slowing charm was used to stop
quaffles from falling straight to the
ground and instead made them slowly
descend so that quidditch players didn't
need to slow down the pace of the game
by grabbing the balls from the pitch
orabella Nutley The Mending charm has
been shown to be quite a versatile piece
of magic if used properly the
incantation is able to repair almost any
inanimate object that has been broken
but the spell surprisingly isn't even
that old it was created by a witch named
orabella Nutley only a few hundred years
before the rise of Lord Voldemort's
Nutley who was employed by the ministry
of magic used the spell in the aftermath
of an incident the Colosseum in Rome
where she was forced to repair the
millennia-old building urquhart
rakharrow urkhart rack Harrow was an
accomplished healer in The Wizarding
community and lived in the mid 17th
century although you might suspect that
much of the Wizarding World like that of
Muggles suffered from a lack of
sophisticated medicine you'd be wrong
Wizards and witches had almost always
been exceptional healers and were able
to cure almost any more formality that
they were Afflicted with so when we look
at rakhara's most famous spell the
entrail expelling curse it's hard to
figure out exactly what the healthcare
provider was trying to achieve some
thought this spell literally caused a
target's colon to be ripped from their
inside sides and drawn out of their body
but rakharo as we've already mentioned
wasn't a dark wizard of any type he
wouldn't have used the charm to cause
harm so in all actuality the spell
probably just alleviates the symptoms of
constipation in its Target although the
students of Hogwarts probably didn't
waste time using it with ill intent
herpa the fowl herpa the fowl might have
been the most powerful dark wizard of
the ancient world any Wizarding
historian would tell you that herpo was
a terrible Sorcerer And would probably
point to his creation of the Basilisk as
his most horrifying contribution to
Magic but there was one more thing that
he made that might have been even worse
it was herpo who devised a way to
fracture a soul and preserve it in
physical objects so that dark wizard
could unnaturally prolong their life
this was the spell that Tom Riddle would
use to survive his first death and it
was Tom Riddle's horcruxes that would
ultimately take Albus Dumbledore's life
and that's it for this video do you want
a part two there are still more witches
and wizards to cover let me know in the
comments until next time remember it
does not do to dwell on dreams and
forget to live